coding is a big part of harshad lingam's
job as a software engineer in Berlin he
works for several major firms he's been
in Germany for several years and is
hoping to get permanent residency but as
an Indian citizen he says there are
difficulties they would ask for one
additional document and then they come
back and then it gets delayed for two
months a one and a half month more
yeah so one of those apart from that and
I didn't like personally didn't face
language issues at the offices
but in terms of employment yes and that
is something the current German
government wants to eliminate they say
their country needs 400 000 new skilled
migrants every year to make up for its
aging population in the future we will
focus more on the qualifications and
professional experience of immigrants
and less informalities we will make it
easier for immigrants to take up
vocational training or study in Germany
immigration has divided governments
across Europe for decades and this new
move in Berlin has not gone unnoticed
elsewhere of course we have governments
very conservative governments like in
Poland who still use migration as a very
combat-like expression of
um yeah of more in interior policy issue
way more than looking for the needs of
the labor market such thoughts are not
held just in Warsaw the Austrian
government recently voted down a plan to
allow bulgar area and Romania into the
eu's borderless Schengen Zone its
Chancellor believes some European
Frontiers need physical barriers Austria
is more than burdened we have over 100
000 Asylum applications more than 75 000
cross the eu's external border cross
member states and were only then
apprehended in Austria we need stronger
external Border Protection we must
finally break the taboo of fences
fences are already up between Hungary
which is inside the Schengen Zone and
Serbia which is not this was a recent
photo call arranged between leaders of
both countries at their border the issue
of migration will be discussed at a
special EU Summit in February but the
political fault lines are clear so as
the New Year Dawns the EU finds itself
with the same old problems
part of the solution can be found here
and can apply across the board but other
parts really can't
Dominic Kane Al Jazeera Brussels